foreign
Baltimore hey Jack how are you
hey Dave and Ken thanks for taking this
call sure I'm just going to find out
um if I should move forward with uh
selling my home or taking a chance
um to remain in it and possibly sell it
next summer uh here's the issue that's
going on right now currently behind uh
close to seventy thousand dollars uh on
my mortgage you're behind seventy
thousand dollars
yes how much is your house payment
um house payment is
about 20 about 2300 so that's about two
and a half three years
how in the world have you gotten two or
three years behind they haven't
foreclosed on you
um oh it was covered yeah okay yeah so
they're just now getting around to you
the post coveted foreclosures are
catching up now okay so if they started
foreclosure yet
yeah no they haven't uh I went through
the Lost mitigation process which was a
grueling process my application was
accepted
um I did receive a a trial payment plan
this past Saturday the the payments uh
well it's a three-month payment plan uh
the payments are feasible definitely can
afford it
um however
on this past Monday I received a letter
from my lender stating that my uh my
loan was being sold
uh to a new lender what kind of a loan
do you have FHA V A or conventional uh
VA loans okay the launch mitigation was
approved by the VA then the lender it'll
go with the loan
okay the new lender will the new lender
will honor this
okay all right and then the other thing
is we during this process since we was
waiting to hear back uh if we were going
to basically receive a payment plan or
not we put our house on the market uh we
did receive an offer uh
uh if we were to move forward with the
offer
um it can potentially after the payoff
amount net us uh I'm close to 100K
okay so let me ask you this why um why
are you three years behind on your house
uh lost income
for three years
yeah
okay are you back why did you lose why
did you not work for three years
uh disability reasons
okay
um so was the disability permanent
uh yes it's permanent and I just started
back working again within the means of
my disability so what do you make
uh right now household with my wife
about just a little over 200k as of
right now
get the new job what was the nature of
your disability sir
um
you're going to I mean from physical
ailments to mental elements I'm a uh 100
disabled veteran oh okay okay well thank
you for your service yes sir
um which is another reason you got lost
mitigation from the VA okay
um
how long have you lived in this house
uh for about
five years I believe about five years if
I'm in your shoes and I've been through
the hell that you all have been through
um the last thing I want to do
is uh walk through mud Knee Deep for the
next many many many many months trying
to get current
when I have a good offer on the table
that gives me a fresh start
I'm selling this puppy and taking a
fresh start clean take the white board
erase everything off the white board now
we got a fresh clean Grace filled
windshield looking forward
if I look in the rear of your mirror I'm
going to see some piles of poop but
looking out the windshield is clean
you follow me
yes and I really personally like that
kind of fresh start feeling you've got a
real opportunity to do that here
um it involves moving which is a pain in
the butt but you know you make 200 a
year you got 100 in your pocket and this
problem is gone
I really like that yeah
okay you see why do you get it's not
really a financial thing as much as it's
emotional and you're going to end up
either way you're going to end up with a
house but you're going to have to go
through
I mean every time you pay double triple
payments it's like a a bell going off in
your head reminding you of the
disability you just clawed your way
through
but if you don't have that you just got
a fresh new life then you've got a fresh
new life you know you don't have
something reminding you of the past
every time you write a dadgum check you
know what I'm talking about
totally understand and I I just think
there's some mental
Health to that if I'm in your shoes now
I've never been in your shoes literally
where I served and I you know came home
uh you know with disabilities uh and
I've never had that problem but I have
had the problem of my past following me
around we all have had that problem
right
and so I I just I can relate to you in
that regard and I just I personally love
a very clean
Fresh Start that's why I like when
someone for instance goes through a
divorce make sure that everything is
paid and clear and clipped we don't keep
paying payments together we're not
married anymore get it all cleaned up
get it separate you want the X to be an
X you know you don't want a half but
still be tied in well we got the kids
make that the only thing you got
together everything else needs to be
clean because that way you can get on
with the second chapter of your life the
third chapter of your life whatever it
is you can't close the last chapter and
I just want to close your last chapter
for you because I care about you and I
just I hear it in your voice I want the
cleanliness I'm taking the deal I'm gone
yeah and take your time if you've got to
rent for a season yeah do it you got a
great combined income yeah assuming that
you're looks like you're pretty healthy
you're cleared uh the best is yet to be
here and I think Dave is absolutely
right I wouldn't even think twice about
this I would clean it all up and begin
the process of re-entering he's been in
a long season of healing and hurting and
all the stress of the house I I
absolutely agree Dave I think you
absolutely right here this is new Square
I think you're I think your wife's gonna
feel like that you took a uh you know
actually been walking around carrying
something on her shoulders and she gets
to set it down yeah like breathe Yeah
clean
cool Mountain Air
peace that's what I want here that's
what I'm after and I want to just on
behalf of Dave and our entire audience
point out that Jack's a true American
hero a great American that would put his
life on the line to serve our country
and have to deal with all this junk uh
this is this is tough stuff and we're
really hoping and praying and cheering
you on that this next chapter is going
to be the best so thank you for who you
are and uh you got this we're gonna walk
alongside of you you got it Jack